let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 see what's on people's minds
very big Newsweek let's go to our caller
from the three four zero area code
caller from three four zero tell us who
you are you can jump right into your
question hello yeah this is Riley I'm
from the United States version Ireland
still part of the United States for a
time being my question is I've been
hearing quite a lot about social
democracies and that's sort of further
left and I'm normally used to sort of
thinking and as I've been sort of
digging into it I'm beginning to realise
that I don't really have any sources any
sort of information any articles any
companions of information about this
sort of thinking when it comes to
economics when it comes to our social
policy and that sort of thing and I want
to know what would you even recommend to
somebody who's sort of delving into this
for the first time well have you at
least done a google search and just
looked at yesterday of these movements
and some of the key thinkers within them
yeah rather than what you do you start
there then you look at who is quoted in
a lot of those writings and then you
look at their work and then you can
start to build up knowledge about it now
I'm curious I think more interesting
than me listing sources would be you
said that social democracy is a little
bit to the left of where you are so
social democracy just means well
regulated capitalism with a priority on
social welfare what about that is too
far left to you well the thing is that
my frame of mind coming out before I
move towards finding interest in that
was generally all good you could you
just fix anything with just a little bit
of capitalism you could fix anything
with and then you maybe save a little
bit of the edge off of that but as I
started to think about it more more
shaving and more shaving than there is
actually solving issues by a broader
markets or what have you and my team's
my thinking has just changed on this but
you've moved to the left or to the right
is what I'm trying to understand I've
moved to the left I've moved to the left
here okay but you're saying that social
damar
Krissy is too far so are you is social
democracy to your left or to your right
it is to my left when I say that I'm
also moving further left I have been
also listening to people who are even
further left in social democracy
recommending social democracy is sort of
a transition point yeah but so like okay
let me ask you specifically on the issue
of healthcare what would you be your
solution to healthcare let's see if
maybe that helps us figure out where you
are in on the spectrum my solution was
government subsidized health care not
single-payer my solution would have been
a situation much like Obama care if it
wasn't so so deeply gutted right now
where people get incentives to buy
health care much of the same that that
people are given incentives to insure
their cars but okay yeah I mean that
actually is slightly to the right of
social democracy so so yeah that that on
that one that does make sense all right
very good well listen plenty of good
resources online start with the wiki
articles look at the source lists and
then you know you can develop a good
reading list for yourself very short
introduction to socialism is also good
it covers both sort of like state
socialism and social democracy I just
read that recently so a couple one idea
for you there thank you
all right very good appreciate the call
great to hear from the US Virgin Islands
it is as he said for now still part of
the part of the United States